Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! I just got a chance
to see Jurassic World it was a ton of fun.
Since most you probably haven't seen it yet
him and to do a non-spoilery review first
and then I'll do specific moments with spoilers
so here we go if you guys haven't watched
any of the other Jurassic Park movies in a
while it's been about 14 years since Jurassic
Park 3 that's how long it's been so the big
task of this movie was to reinvigorate the
franchise which I I feel like it did pretty
good you have Chris Pratt is blowing up all
over the World right now he's like the next
Harrison Ford which is funny because it did
get a bit of an Indiana Jones vibe off his
character we even got the kingpin Vincent
D'onofrio you which is it's kind of funny
watching him do this after doing daredevil
begot Jake Johnson who you probably know from
new girl Kate McGrath you probably remember
from Merlin is a bunch of familiar faces is
only one actor from the previous Jurassic
Park films though he was a geneticist in the
first film he's basically playing the same
character he played in that film pretty pretty
much the entire main cast is new his character
does a good job of linking aspects of that
first film to this film is it's almost like
they're re-starting the cycle so you see a
lot of Easter eggs for for previous films
but mostly for the first film is anything
that this film does really well and it definitely
captures a lot of the humor and awkwardness
of going to like a giant theme park just filled
with bodies of people it's so perfect for
the disaster movie genre that's what Jurassic
Park movies are there disaster movies like
San Andreas only it's the dinosaurs that are
the earthquake in even though we have star
Lawrence ran into a lot of like really funny
performances from the actors the dinosaurs
are still the main stars the film is, going
to a Transformers movie or tell like a ninja
turtles movie you don't go to see Megan Fox
you go to see the robots and the turtles do
something just absolutely crazy that's why
this is such an awesome summer popcorn movie
you know you did you just go for like a really
awesome roller coaster ride thematically I
think that's why the Jurassic Park movies
work so well like that the way that they built
them because it's a theme park you go to theme
parks to go on rides the movie itself is,
like a roller coaster ride the a story the
film is all about this dinosaur disaster the
be story and a lot of the subtext in the morality
people can be every bit as bad or are even
worse than giant man eating dinosaurs Steven
Spielberg is a director that's known for like
is very visual storytelling style and even
though he didn't direct this film there's
a lot from his original Jurassic Park films
late into this at the end of the day though
Jurassic Park is a franchise so Jurassic World
this movie is not going to be the last one
by and by any means like I said they're trying
to reinvigorate the franchise there couple
clear setups in the movie that they give you
some ideas about where the next one might
go they haven't made any indications about
when that movies going to, or what the cast
is going to be but I'll talk about the little
bit more and spoilers because the ending does
give you pretty good idea about how they're
going to escalate the next movie some of talk
about my favorite moments from the film now
stood just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet here we go starting with number
five dinosaurs are starting to get boring
the whole starting point for the disaster
in this movie was the creation of the Indominus
Rex like you know that the big villain of
the movie they created him because they felt
like people were getting bored with the normal
dinosaurs that's a big source of comity in
the film is a big joke is Chris Pratt's like
dinosaurs are exciting enough by themselves
Whitey need to make some crazy monster dinosaur
sponsored by Verizon no less that was actually
a great joke in the film Verizon was actually
a real-life sponsor the film like the gave
the Jurassic World people bunch of monies
that username and the film they said they
were totally fine with that with the fact
that the Indominus Rex kills a bunch of people
but be just like the publicity so it's a joke
in the film but it's also a real-life product
placement thing this also gets into like the
subtext of the film you know what is it say
about us as people if we become bored with
something as crazy is dinosaurs somatically
the also tieback that the two young boys and
with that the older one is just only interested
in looking at girls like he asked week could
care less about the dinosaurs in the park
the consequence of that being is like you
know when you don't take dinosaurs we don't
take these big things seriously things go
crazy that's what Chris Pratt's character
is shouting through the entire movie is like
these are real animals they don't care that
they were made in a test tube all they want
to do is hunt eat and reproduce so the big
message of the film is respect nature or face
the consequences which also kind leads into
what the sequels probably can end up being
onto number four Henry Wu and Vincent that
offer euros character create a genetic monster
for the military you could just tell the minute
someone said I'm not allowed to tell you what
DNA is inside this dinosaur that it was going
to turn out to be like some crazy freak is
annoyed any time someone in a film withholds
important information like that in a crisis
you kinda know that they're going to turn
out to be the villain so you want to point
to the real villains of the film it's Dr.
Henry Wu and Vincent in our Frio visits an
offer is actually in gentlepersons so technically
in general the villains and you could actually
say that of all the Jurassic Park films the
only difference between the geneticist in
this film and the other films are that the
other films they seemed a little bit more
neutral here he almost goes into maniacal
laughter when he is talking to Omar side he's
the guy that placed the CEO Seo's like I'm
shutting this down and Henry was like you
wouldn't have any of this if it wasn't for
me so very clearly the villain in that situation
let me know if you figured out early on which
dinosaurs that big dinosaur was made of the
gave you a lot of clues with the footprint
and in the way it smelled its prey like a
really close it's a giant summer movies so
it's made to be pretty easy to follow so like
you can take a little kid to it and they should
be able to figure out what that giant dinosaur
is moving onto number three the Indominus
Rex is a T Rex velociraptor hybrid there was
a lot of DNA from other animals in there to
like that that's what the lab seem was for
them going through all the tanks you know
like the snake the lizard that could change
colors but the two big ones birds T Rex and
velociraptor so it was you really big and
aggressive like a T Rex but is really smart
and fast like a velociraptor the reason that
they created it is because Vincent in our
Frio was trying to sell a military contract
so they wanted to create this living weapon
so he went to the geneticist and said I'll
give you 800 money if you make this for me
that's why at the end of the film whenever
he was escaping whenever he was flying off
the helicopter he took all those embryos the
important thing to remember especially for
the sequel is is that he got off the island
with those embryos so they can make more Indominus
Rex is onto number two Chris Pratt's raptor
pack this is one of the most fun things about
the film you take the villain from the previous
Jurassic Park films and you make them your
friends as crazy as that seems they did to
give themselves like a back door with the
logic you know they're still very vicious
it's like trying to train giant liens so Chris
Pratt's character very wisely says I don't
control them it's a relationship which is
why you know during the middle of the movie
the raptors turn on them and follow the new
alpha pack mentality if you've ever watched
a werewolf movie you know there's always an
alpha and beta like this a lot of that logic
built into the film if the new alpha comes
along that's more powerful the pack will switch
allegiance just think of the idea of domesticated
raptors though like so domesticated they would
put them in that petting zoo but finally my
number one moment in the film T Rex versus
Indominus Rex this is an even better example
of turning the villain of the previous movies
into the hero of this film so is much as the
film puts Chris Pratt Ford is the hero the
film and he's a total bad ass the T Rex with
a lot of help from blue here and aquatic dinosaur
are the big heroes of the film really the
biggest success the film is getting you to
fall in love with that velociraptor that helps
the T Rex to feed the Indominus Rex like he
almost sacrifices himself it's a very lassie
old yeller type moments of you've ever seen
those movies he ever seen old yeller and you
see the boys relationship with the dog that's
kind like Chris Pratt's relationship with
the velociraptor's. My big question for you
guys you know what was your favorite moment
from the film and did you love those velociraptor's
by the end like you feel like the film was
successful in getting you to love them I feel
like anybody that's owned a dog or a large
pet will totally understand the the emotional
roller coaster that film takes you on it does
hit a lot of the same beats that animal movies
hit like that it's like Chris Pratt Marley
and me except instead of the dog it's a velociraptor
there were a whole bunch Easter eggs the film
to those so let's talk about a couple of the
big ones first Jake Johnson T-shirt in case
you missed it the T-shirt that Jake Johnson
is wearing when you first meet them in the
film and that control room is the logo from
the original Jurassic Park film there were
a lot of moments where the film was making
fun of itself this park is going to be way
better than the original park you know giant
air quotes Jake Johnson's character himself
is like an alternate universe good version
of Wayne Knights character from the first
film in case you don't remember him he was
the guy that played Newman on Seinfeld use,
like a dirt bag in the first film Jake Johnson's
character is kind like the show love like
he is only he turns out to be a hero in this
film like is that this movie takes a lot of
the evil stuff from the first couple of films
flips it and makes a good so velociraptor's
T Rex Newman all good in this film the other
biggest Easter eggs in the film though were
when the kids actually went to the original
park the open the doors to what looks like
this hidden Temple and if in the main hall
of the the original park with like all those
old cars 1993 Jeep Wrangler like even said
out loud this is a like a lot of small Easter
eggs two a lot of small visual Easter eggs
like the little cartoon from the first film
that explains DNA they turn that into a hologram
that was playing in like that main room and
the one really awesome Bryce Dallas Howard
East rate you knows when she she grabbed the
flare and release the T Rex that was a nice
oh March 1 film were Sando use that flair
to distract the T Rex the only big criticism
of the film I've seen is the Deus ex Machina
and with the aquatic dinosaur getting the
Indominus Rex and Napoleon into the bay I
felt like it totally worked given that this
movie is meant to be like a fun popcorn movie
but you you could argue that that, came out
of nowhere but it's like trying to criticize
a fast and furious movie for twist in its
logic like is not meant to portray reality
like this is pure fantasy but in case you
guys are watching this and you haven't seen
it yet be sure to go see it is a lot of fun
there definitely going to be making more films
next film is probably going to follow-up with
the doctor trying to make more Indominus Rex
is in them getting loose all over the World
think about it this way the film is called
Jurassic World but it you know it is a play
on Disney World somatically think about what
that might mean for the entire World that
the dinosaurs get out of the Indominus Rex
is get out unstoppable killing machines loose
all over the World I feel like that's where
the franchises headed it's a disaster movie
franchise so why not turn the island disaster
into a World disaster you guys can let me
know you know where do you feel like the sequel
is going to go to do you feel like they're
going to make more of these and they'll get
loose all over the World? there couple other
big movies that are coming this summer in
the next couple weeks including Ant Man and
Fantastic Four I'll totally be doing videos
for them so so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff, if there's any other movies
you guys want me to do videos for just let
me know I'm just trying to do more movie videos,
while you wait for all that stuff, in other
epic disasters this weekend the game of thrones
finale is coming up so you can click here
to learn all about the Night's King and Azor
Ahai and you can click here to learn all about
the punisher coming to daredevil season 2
thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!